для чого вони інкремують ну ц в
нормальному демократичному суспірстві з
метою ти смішну нікчемну Я б мені це
тут сказала ще перед тренуванням
Я не знаю
[музика]
то й
небезпека І ось я заросвячений чоловікові
пройти
я буду видно що я буду своєю Україною
що я буду поговорити за своїм
я лисейнова Людмила Мені 60 руки я три
руки була в полоні на купоні території
назотриммели за мої про українські
націоналістичні нібито покарали
подивіться і звідти допоможу яку я
надавала дітям
проживаючим на купонних територіях якщо
вийшло 14 уроці
моєму місці
бойових дій Путін так стало Вся біда
накрила наше місце хто з них поїхав
летить ви вирішили залишитися ми залишилися з
допомогою навірилася що все так довго
буде ми сподівалися але ми протрималися
стружки стружки і всі були добрі всі
стали станції так я половина статусі
і взагалі ми поїдемо це все. Скажіть ну
теж усі теж України тут не буду Миколи
Бог усі знали які погляд Поляни
моєї родини
а Путін я впізнала ще не виїхавши дитячий
інтернат до ранку при Україні буфф
проти Приморському селі нашого району
так залишилося
перестали фінансувати цю інтернет
і
на волокуму там протити і ти їхніх дітей
дали Можна сказати і так от роздали ті
сім'ї які чималі
достатку
обійдуся так Вранці ось цих дітей я не
знала секунда приїхала Я була
шокована тому що діти недоїдали
Чому тих ти і ми вирішили
ще будемо працювати все можна війни можна
було ще допомагати їм дітям Я
повернулася до своїх знайомих елітних ранку
проживала на лінії території України та
ми враховувалася кілька людей на адже
знаємо їх нам скільки людей прийняла
участь вжити сил дітей ми Тім дітям
дали розуміння ще по ту лінію
набори для а там живуть люди
які
приймуть їх і кучері про них покинуть Я
думаю ще
на вигляд за
розвами Ти де ти вже природи коліні
знаю я складу вся їхня частка Я думаю ще на
вид за Раз он тача спинка кохання і
доброти до
ромадян України у серцях усіх дітей
завершилася і знає ще все кохання вона
заклалася на купоні території проти
всіх
[музика]
ми забрали під ерозі на роботу Я тільки
вийшла з
двору та приїхала машина вискочив йти
два
флопчали там телефон забрав саме в
свою контуру і я ночувала таке ж ще
страшні так і лишилося Я думала ну що
ну телефон Ви знаєте яка Я
відкрита не виходить там на майдані
нікого не до чого вона закликаю
з автоматом вас не стріляю Ну так таким
мені поле Так я їх не змінила висипатися
знала я думала ще так Ну за раз у цьому
Абу штраф Я випише тобою ну 15 добу
рукавич
а ось скажи ти такий собі там 5
телефон
вони там показують
тренує але все нормальному
демократичному суспірстві з
смішно нікчемну
беб і стало ще
дуже у дядька на всій Україні за 1000 до
допомагають дітям КТ проживає на купівлі
території та всього допису слово
окупована ось так уже було
лінгвістичні
обстежена Якір мій там експертом і
ціни визнання Республіки млинці жителі
Республіки
там ще я їх не визнаю так нісенітниця
просто за чотири за п'ять руки о 14 по 19
Місяця чи знаєш
близькості епізоді
з них здебільшого Я просто лайкнула
я Києву начитаю Що за п'ять руки в 50
епізодів ранку підпадають під їх статтю
про екстремізм не визнання Влади та
шпигунство
відкритий фейсбучний студент
я знала де
камеру ми напхнули
зняли ту пов'язку і
Дівчата дівчаток вже там була вона
сказала то ізоляція Я до чого читала про
то ізоляцію де мені стало довго
лячью скажемо так я дурнень Навіть боялася
ще в мене буде адвокат це було ще в
ізоляції і дівчата раз побачила ще там
є Каста так звана адвокат на рік
розфарбувалася МГб
іншак не допускають я буду допускають Ну
медузи
і я хочу щоб дівчата виднілася А
адже адвокаті на рік
наймали пологи чим ще така дівчат б'ють
тобто тут-то Приму в цій сяде
адвокаті у нас у камері Марина була і
Мамо
найняла адвоката уклала договір з
плати плати адвокату та привезли до
наступного тикаєш 3D адвоката ти весь
наш ручку і запишеш що ти
надихаєшся вона чогось так
зайшли час вивела і в туалет
було тільки зрозуміла Чому так і ось
Колима не привезли до наступного лука
був уже лише місяць я була на ізоляції
наряд тут тієї самої покритий робота
целофановий тютюн так це
нічого не бачив А папірець
поки ти займаєшся
Ти називаєш прізвище
намагається ахтутися я скажу я не знаю
правда
гвинт уявної з адвокат вашої лінії найняв
І вам адвокати Я навіть натякалася б
думаю я до мене грубуватий ся ви зараз
потягнути А ось тут ти обійду тег
краще почала ще з тон доглядати з
дитячих руки Я фарбую падає і я група
Бато-ся потім ще страшно вона щастя
Мені адвокат якість
вдома Ось і всі його завищили
евін не відразу сказавши що ви розумієте ми
в такій системі живим але відомо ще
ще але ще вам можуть ви просто там ще
слайкнули робітник сказала Алые розрих
розраховують і на 1000 Цельсія
закиньшитися виправданням на моїй
сенсорні Будди такого не було
несподіваного епізоду за все за вас
зараз він сказав черги
подали на обмін
і вся сподіваюся Ну давай ти вже потерпимо
від руки там скільки де кілька місяць
може до Нового уроку Будди вогняні всі
налагодиться Я тему навіть зародила думаю два
місяця боже Ну я купу ж приходить
в тому покриття Я б мені це сказала ще
Я не знаю
я не знаю взагалі
у роті було б не трудитися знатою.
ми жили без ЧАЕС і инча дівчата все
чікали новина нуд заріс доброю Рік
може ж Великдень А ми ж ризик 2 а може якісь
ми там ставили собі Ми ж великі Свято
ще одну ось заросте будете
Ну я косить так от ми прожив ці три
руки Я вперше
можна до 10 року не вечора сидять
темпаче
класти лягає назовні
так стало Все думали висока Нора і там
штир залізний
цілий день ти ходиш облаштуєш і вашу
Швидке віддалення до 10 вечора
я без 10 вийшла все, що ти
лягти
на Нару А ти новачкамері я підкоряюсь
двері топовим відро покрито і захоплено
до стіни
іриску шинкуються двері дуже грязні
слова я першу чаруш де того покрите
сива на ту руку не знаю До речі я
розгорнута охоронець
скидаємо з іншого поверху Нари я падаю
було більш ніж
і так Ми там не можна
порушувати такі
нормою до відривини встановили я зараз ось
сіджусбама
я
метущі боюся коли
рук і я звикла
диво-було світло в камеру
тобто
небезпека І ось я зараз я не можу
пройти
риба група на адресу
Я чесно скажу ще я дихаю блокую
і
навчилася ти роботи там буякший думаєш
ти можеш твій страх забути А чого він
це
вимагає
впали ж у такі місця в ізоляцію в
в'язницю там ще
переломи ти собою настільки вивернуто з
інший ти так, щоб ти нікого не боялася
б взагалі ти хочеш Хочеш здригнешся
покажеш що ти боїшся все
тобі просто не суть в зіб'ють і будуть
помічатися ще більше
вільного доступу на молодому та на
адвокат ми могли чогось загострити загальну
злитчі виклики І взагалі вени плещемо
адвокатулефонович від адвокат прийшов
думаю навіть просила ще до в'язниці б там і
вже лісову жінку порядок
Якісінчі закони все вже зустрічав на неї
ховати із СІЗО
будуть такі щасливі обличчя жінки
Що з вами
таки заради А я була рада бою по
території в'язниці прокидалася б з
пакета на голові
вичвиділа обличчя я бачила
сонце
два місяці
Я вже боялася ще мені я тільки жити
приліпити будь-який бік
я така щаслива що я вирвалася ті
ізоляції
зайшла вже на саму в'язницю та запах
Ти ж людина запах в'язниці мені досі
день здається що я взагалі не вимилася
вдень
і підкоряються двері камера
Там п'ять двоярусних спарених між
собою нар і 20 земний Вже стало 20 енок
Івани усі палять
він варить там тепер на окропі
борщу та рулет засмажку
і там
ганчірочку
така фіранка і з ганчіркою А тут і
фіранку
раковина і дірка в полі чи туалет і
над тим туалетом ти миєш митися ми
ватою чистоті зуби Бон і дракони можна
спеціально їх 20
щеня
мої ж половина
Місяця на хворі на СНІД
і ти розуміє ще там проблеми із зубами я
кістою рани
то все Чисті зуби над тією діркою в
туалеті
ми закривали цю дірку пляшку та пряжку
з-під води надувало
просто воду і закривала цю дірку був
Ветеранів Та й щури як його ти і так з
морок що
але можна я навіть довго
не звукала до тіла
звукала на з рота ти на цілу хвилю для
душа ти на повні груди
вдихати тобто морок дуже вашку було
грудні життя
Будьте брутальним
у тих розмолах КТ
у тому за вітром
у тому й туалеті
я собі казала треба
всі пережиті
Намагайтеся не
занурювати свої там ось ці проблеми
проживання все-таки
мені за раз самій голову я вийти і акції я
пережила
відомі були такі моменти з ВІЛ та
близько
ти чекаєш тут зарачу потерпай навіть
тисячі я сумнівалася я буду обмінена я
буду в Україні
люблю тих Їм ми з дівчатами
[сміх]
сумнівалася такі такі бувалий моменти
в тому
емоційні
фізичні
ти засинаєш
чисто там валеріанку випиваєш намаєшся
заснуті закриті боїшся
відкриті б ти плачеш
тяжко було але я нахлину у мене не було
сумніву ще я буду видно що я буду
своїй Україні що я буду поговорити за своїм
Я про ще хочу сказати ще млинець ніж не
до кропу але відомого перчика там
декель до там місяцем у Ной було таке
видіння кропка ще одна я ктирки я
зайшла сказала статтю він ще одна кропка
де було все в камері Коли почалася вина
там був телевізор Ми маже його дубово то
це ключа все і на природі виступав
Путін з промиваю
у всі передачі кристали тільки його
показувала І всі замили ми всі мурчики
слухали все було страшно і вже
писали прогулянки
Я трохи там читала
вичиняється двері Мені дають 20 на збори
нічого, а дівчина яка там залишилася
Оля
вона сказала мені здається ще те саме
я ти шприц замовила не мало дитинка
я забрав і так вже за лайки
Вона вела і нехай там активну
діяльність вона просто лайкала висловлювала
свої позиції в соціальному морі може
там Деш і списала і Коли винайшов це
було дві руки цьому їжі не краще було
чотири роки його вона так довелося нам ще
мені стало Ну я губу Ми не такі вибір
робота мислення ти взагалі взяла
шилась би і забрати тебе я заверталась
до всіх
і казала причіп і мені тяжко
тут спати і в чисті чиступий стиль
вибочети ванної Будди
знаєш це Оля дючку і так і митися
лягає
постили брудний вигляд клопієвий вигляд
смуроду
і не знають що там їжі
весь свій вид нас у мишках Ви ж високі
такі коридори було чашку і ти дівчатам
було лякана скотчем замотала руки дуже
погрозив цю машину ми такі холодні
навіть духу а Путін дружину нас
хлопсі сказала ще геть і російські
військові і ми на території Росії
ще нас привезли до Таганрогу
Але чому труха плакати дівчина була
і сказав ще тотмен ми вже я ще Персі
там годинник Ми думали то це вже такі
суми було навіть Великий розумів ще
дієті вивантажили і нас посадили в тій
літак вантажна людина
і насичені дівчатам вже
скронево-полонинами яких привезли
нішами машинами вже сильну сказала якщо
дати на прийменнику літака і сидіти
ялинкою
ти розсовуєшся так ноги і до ТБ
сива іншаїнка
у нас
Так ти намаєш потрібні вести ніяк
ворухливість
дівчата там
плакала було вже більш ніж
а ось і нічого не може рубає рубає це
так ось сидиш і ялинку зайшовши купа Богу
ми години за два прильоти тілли і вже Стіл
всього літака ми виповзали і ми
побачила ще на Джанкої ще ми їдемо
Куди все було ціни друзів мило Дістань
хвалити
була потилиця
ми вже самі займали ті скотчі із собою
нам дозволили вийти
по прізвищу викликали поставила і то
Діма вже прийшли
ми побачили нашого хлопця Стім білим
кланом
і ми йшли та кричала і Слава Україні
героєм Слава
встигав гімну це емоції
до утрин уже пори б то нічого
і ти божевільного страшні там
залишилося ззаду до того ще для мене
залишилося позаду
я знаю що там робиш дівчата вгамувати
про всю
свободу
сказати ці слова вільну і голосно
і стрибають ранок Я дуже минулі турботи та
навіть минулого ти ж витковато завищити
вирубати з можна
знайти дівчата пумині ніби на їх волі
діти полину ніби поряд з нами
[музика]